the White House released a really weird
Christmas video it's been totally
polarizing here's the
[Music]
[Applause]
video
[Music]
so if you're just listening to this now
there's not all that much to describe
it's you can hear the tap dancing going
on lot of extremely colorful outfits and
personalities one one might confuse the
White House here for the Senate
Judiciary hearing room and you know as
one might expect from the Democrats who
put such a focus on race and racial
diversity you know it's
uh you know to to totally out of Central
casting in that regard I kind of like
the video I kind of like it let me just
say kind of here because it's not a good
video but the reason it's not good is
not because of the concept of the video
I really like the concept of it I like
to focus on tap dancing tap dancing is a
really fun wholesome art form very
traditional American art
form the reason the video is not good is
because it it's not good tap
dancing it's not I don't mind the
colorful costumes are a little weird
they're they're a little on the
flamboyant Democrat side but whatever I
don't really care about that the
extremely on the- nose diversity casting
is I I have no problem with people of
all walks of life tap dancing it's it's
on the nose the Democrats are always
just so conspicuous about this sort of
thing but again I don't that doesn't
bother me in the least some of some of
my favorite tap dancers are black guys
you know Gregory Hines or Samy Davis Jr
the reason it's bad tap dancing gets to
an issue at the heart of leftist
politics which is that it's too
self-indulgent good really good tap
dancing is subtle it's understated it's
elegant you think of people like Fred a
stair you think of people like Jean
Kelly when they when they tap danceing
or Gregory Hines or Sammy Davis Jr any
of any of these other tap dancers that
I've mentioned or not
mentioned their really beautiful tap
dancing is when you can hardly see the
moves and you just hear the Click Click
you know and it's it's just elegant it's
graceful their feet are moving at you
know a rapid Pace while their body is
just so elegant there's the sense of
Stillness and confidence and integrity
that's missing in the in the White House
video it's it looks like an element
tap class where every movement is just
so exaggerated and the biggest Smiles it
actually looks like the scene in Singing
in the rign with Jean Kelly where it's a
flashback
to uh to Jean Kelly's bad days doing the
vaudville circuit you know fit as a
fiddle ready for
love and it's where all of the uh the
mannerisms are exaggerated and it's it's
a funny scene it's a delightful scene
but it's funny in that what he's doing
here
is expressing a bad
dance that's what's going on here and
and it's just true of all of our modern
politics there's no sense anymore of
understatement of Elegance of humility
of of subtlety that's gone now
everything has to be so exaggerated
everyone has to be so uh prideful and
over-the-top and constantly drawing
attention to themselves in in
unattractive ways that's that's what I
don't like about it but I do like I do
like the tap dancing I just think about
today how many more exclamation points
you see in correspondence in the old
days in the days of Jean Kelly Freda
stere Gregory hin Sammy Davis Jr people
rarely used exclamation points in their
correspondents because an exclamation
point is like laughing at your own joke
it's an exclamation point is like this
White House tap dancing video
it
it's it's so unnecessary it's so
gratuitous today if you send a text
message or even a professional email
without 75 exclamation points people are
going to think you're a sociopath
they're they're going to think you're a
stone cold
killer it gets to that that underlying
rot then the final problem with the
White House tap dancing video is I don't
I don't think they were actually
recording the Taps I think those Taps
were added in after the fact I'm not
positive but the Taps don't really seem
to line up with the foot movements
probably because the White House is just
not wired for tap dancing it's not like
a big tap stage in any case a good idea
I want to give the Biden White House I
Joe Biden was the one who posted this uh
I want to give them credit for having a
nice impulse but you got to land the
execution too they did not right now
text nolles to 98 9898 diversify your
savings with physical precious medals
while stockpiling silver in your home
safe take advantage of bir gold group's
most popular special of the year now
through December 22nd for every $5,000
you spend with Birch gold they will send
you a 1o silver eagle coin for free text
nolles kwes to 98 9898 to claim your
eligibility now you can purchase gold
and silver and have it shipped directly
to your home or have Birch Gold's
precious metal Specialists help you
convert an existing Ira or 401K into a
tax sheltered Ira in gold for no money
out of pocket they will send you free
silver for every $5,000 you purchase
keep it for yourself or give something
with real value as a stocking stuffer
this year it's pretty good stocking
stuffer just checks the word nolles to
9898 98 to claim your eligibility with
an A+ rating with the Better Business
Bureau thousands of happy customers now
is the best time to buy gold from Birch
gold text nolles kwes to 998 9898 claim
your eligibility for free silver un
qualifying purchases before December
22nd that is nolles kwes to 98 9898
right now go to expressvpn.com Christmas
is a time of Joy gratitude and
reflection in the midst of these
festivities consider taking a moment to
reflect on the digital footprint that
accompanies you through the season think
about all the information on your phone
your search history your location the
websites you shop at and more companies
can legally gather this information and
sell it to advertisers for massive
profit that is why you need to do what I
do and trust your online security to
expressvpn expressvpn is an app on your
phone and computer that encrypts all of
your online traffic so that all your
online activity remains private if you
think that incognito mode is going to
stop people from tracking your online
activity think again read the fine print
that appears when you start browsing in
incognito mode says that your activity
might still be visible to your employer
your school or your internet service
provider with that expressvpn every site
you visit could be logged by the Admin
of that Network I love expressvpn
because I'm a leite and it's super easy
to use even I can use use it the app has
one button once you turn it on you're
protected from prying eyes daily wire is
partnered with expressvpn to get you a
special Christmas offer go to
expressvpn.com right now get three extra
months for free
expressvpn.com expressvpn.com to learn
more a really great story a really
really great story to close on today
from the Charlotte lure Center uh report
this is a survey that has shown that
pro-life pregnancy centers provided at
least 358 million million dollar in
goods and services to pregnant women
last year that includes half a million
free ultrasounds at least 200,000 tests
for venial disease 700,000 free
pregnancy tests 400,000 parenting
education programs 600,000 students who
took sexual risk avoidance education 4.3
million baby outfits and by the way not
just for the babies and the mothers who
chose to have their children even for
the women who killed their children
abortion 19,000 people received
postabortion support at least probably
the number is much higher than that from
pro-life pregnancy
centers and this is a really good thing
because 32,000 more babies were born
last year than the year before thanks to
State abortion bans in the wake of the
dobs decision I I tell you I I kind of
like this legislating morality doesn't
it work I kind of like the notion that
culture is Downstream of politics I kind
of like the idea that the law is a
teacher because it works it works and
saves 32,000 babies lives and then the
reason I bring up this story at all is
because you always hear the libs say
that conservatives only care about
babies in the womb you hear that one
they've been telling us that for decades
yeah you conserv you care about babies
in the womb you just don't care when
they get out of the womb you mean old
conservatives uh I don't know
did is $358 million not enough that
seems like a lot in just private
donations that's that's
great for all sorts of women including
women who've had abortions it's pretty
good great way just a little that's a
nice little number tuck that number in
$358
million in private donations to women in
need
who are considering abortion who even
had abortion who uh chose to have their
baby heroically who need some help as as
mothers afterward that's a lot of money
and you ask those Libs you say oh yeah
did you what did you give you ever give
$358 million no you oh you've given
nothing to those women in need you've
given nothing to those babies in need
your our answer is to give at least $358
million to help them and and we'll give
more I'll happily give more give me tell
me the number I'm sure the pro-lifers
would give would give that and then
some any number to save to save babies
lives and the libs answer is now we
don't want to give a single red scent we
just we just think you should kill your
baby which is it which which which do
you think is more conducive to a
flourishing Society man what a great
clip that was now hold up hold up hey
hold up ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael nolles podcast we'll see you
next time